the pandemic has hit a lot of businesses
hard but many owners thought this summer
would have been a way a way rather to
make up for that loss eight news now
reporter victoria saha spent the day
with a makeup artist who was bracing for
the worst again she joins us live in the
newsroom with more tonight victoria
makeup artist justine hill thought
business would be booming again and it
was briefly but with the masked mandates
back she says fewer people are not
wanting to get their makeup done she's
describing the situation as the rise
before the fall
justine hall is a self-employed makeup
artist who gives every client her all it
definitely makes me happy and i don't
feel like i'm working when she started
her business before the pandemic hit she
was booked all the time but then the
call stopped i have two kids i'm a
single mom so that was like really scary
because i was like i'm not gonna be able
to feed my kids much longer
slowly only getting a handful of clients
a month having three thousand dollars
worth of bills a month and my income
went to 900 800. hill says she had a
sigh of relief in the beginning of the
summer when the mask mandates were
lifted and life started to seem somewhat
normal again the month of july i did at
least 40. but that sigh of relief only
lasted a few weeks now that the masks
are back on because of the growing
concern over the delta variant now i'm
like kind of getting scared again too as
well so i found that i was getting a lot
of people messaging me asking me prices
when july and june was going on and then
now
i'm not getting any like
silent though she has fewer clients
seeing a client happy gives her the
satisfaction she needs
it is it is real beautiful
she also tells me last year taught her
to be prepared for the worst so as she
as she takes in these few clients she is
making sure to save some money whenever
she can reporting live from the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now